bienvenue bienvenue à tous ravis de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
paris saclay tv nous voici au wild wild
pour où il ya innovation bnp paribas a
choisi massy pour implanter ce lieu
dédié à l'open innovation c'est ici que
s'est déroulée l'inauguration ram une
première édition consacrée à un thème
passionnant l'humain augmenter ou le
transhumanisme alors lui était tout
simplement génial albert einstein serait
peut-être un peu surpris sa théorie sur
la relativité générale est remise en
question par un satellite de l'onera
l'office national d'études et de
recherches aérospatiales
on vous dévoile l'opération microscope
dans un instant alors devant tant
d'innovations
on comprend pourquoi autant de grands
groupes ont choisi votre territoire pour
implanter leurs centres de recherche et
de développement
dernier en date edf visite guidée de
leur site est aujourd'hui opérationnelle
avec jean paul schabas et le directeur
scientifique et le directeur du projet
edf saclay enfin tous ces changements
peuvent surprendre déconcerté voir
inquiéter et dont il faut rassurer
débattre échanger c'est l'objectif de la
concertation à suivre les explications
de lucien shabazz on sait le garant de
cette concertation et enfin notre agenda
tous les événements à ne pas rater dans
les semaines qui viennent ce sera à la
fin de cette émission paris saclay tv
vous fait donc vivre le premier innove
and connect forum du why
le white c'est cet espace dédié à l'open
innovation espaces ouverts dans bnp
paribas à massy est le thème retenu pour
cette première édition était un thème
passionnant l'humain augmenter le
transhumanisme au programme des
conférences mais aussi un concours de
startups
voyez notre reportage
le waï massy saclay et c'est assez
simple son objectif c'est vraiment de
connecter à la fois les chercheurs les
étudiants et les entreprises de
l'écosystème du plateau de saclay et de
le faire dans une dimension ou if c'est
vraiment de connecter à la fois les
chercheurs les étudiants et les
entreprises de l'écosystème du plateau
de saclay et de le faire dans une
dimension où on est intégré au programme
i know and connect innoven connect c'est
quoi son adn c'est de connecter les
clients entreprises de bnp paribas avec
les certain qu'on héberge donc les start
up elles ont besoin client et nos
clients entreprises de bnp paribas elles
ont besoin d'innovation dont sont
porteuses les start up
nous avons choisi le thème de l'humain
augmenté vers le transhumanisme parce
que il intègre à la fois à la
problématique de la robotique de
l'intelligence artificielle et des
implants et on pense que ces trois
thèmes sont au coeur d'une révolution à
la fois industriel et d' usage
le forum il s'adresse à la fois aux
chercheurs à la fois aux étudiants et à
la fois aux entreprises c'est à dire que
ce qu'on essaye de faire
c'est vraiment un lien entre ces trois
univers de faire un pont au maximum pour
qu'ils apportent à chaque fois leur
excellence ils ont tous à apprendre à
partager des choses ensemble donc
typiquement cet après midi on va faire
des ateliers collaboratif où on va avoir
des chercheurs des étudiants et des
entrepreneurs qui vont essayer grâce à
l'intelligence collective de faire
émerger des choses s'est ouvert aux
start up bien évidemment aux entreprises
tpe pme au grand compte vous avez ici
des directeurs d'innovation de grands
groupes
vous avez des pme vous avez des
étudiants vous avez des chercheurs qui
sont là donc l'idée c'est vraiment tous
ceux qui sont intéressés par ce sujet et
d'avoir une ouverture les plus larges
possibles
sur plateau saclay vous avez un
écosystème qui est propice vous avez
safran vous avez à thales vous avez
airbus
vous avez les grands groupes qui sont au
coeur de ces sujets et à côté de ça vous
avez des étudiants des chercheurs qui
aussi sont intéressés et complètement
passionnée par ce sujet
l'innovation c'est aussi ce satellite
conçu dans le cadre de l'opération
microscope objectif défier albert
einstein et sa théorie sur la relativité
générale
rien que ça une expérience menée par
l'onera l'office national d'études et de
recherches aérospatiales
le satellite a déjà été envoyé dans
l'espace il commence à donner quelques
informations quelques mesures tout de
suite les précisions de manuel rodrigues
c'est le chef du projet microscope
mais quand ça patine missions spatiales
qui vise à tester le principe liga
valence
alors qu'est ce que le principe
d'équivalence donc c'est le principe
fondateur de la théorie d'arbitré
générale d'einstein qui dit que tous les
corps quel que soit leur masse ou leurs
compositions vont chuter de la même
façon uniforme
ils vont être accélérés la même manière
en principe il ya lancé de dire qu'ils
avaient l'équivalence entre accélération
et gravité
l'expérience microscope on fait appel un
satellite cette expérience à bord d'un
satellite
le premier challenge ça a été de
réaliser un satellite qui soit avec un
environnement suffisamment calme pour
instrument qui est extrêmement sensible
donc l'onera a réalisé un instrument sur
mesure pour cette expérience et le
challenge était de réaliser un
instrument qui est aux limites de
performance de tout ce qui se réalise
aujourd'hui
donc en termes de mécanique ou un terme
d'électronique ont vraiment aux limites
de l'état de l'art et de pouvoir
assembler tout ça grâce à une équipe qui
a intégré qui j'ai dirait rallye toutes
ces compétences électronique mécanique
physique dans la même équipe au même
endroit on a pu construire un instrument
complexe et une mission complexe piste
on avait aussi la capacité à définir une
mission c deja à définir ce que serait
cette mission comment on allait utiliser
au satellite
la durée des missions ces deux ans
pendant ces deux ans va y avoir des
carrières d'actifs grosso modo trois
mois par an donc on va être de cette
élite
donc on va avoir une grosse ombre de 18
mois pendant lesquels on va pouvoir
faire des expériences lensois du têt du
principe violence dans le vérifie que
l'accélération de de masse soit
identique dans un mouvement dans une
trajectoire autre date air et puis on va
faire d'autres expériences pour essayer
de d'estimé certains paramètres
instrumentaux ou du satellite par
exemple savoir est ce que nous deux
masques sont bien centré à combien elles
sont centrées donc on va faire des
dimensions statines pour ici mais ces
centrales
et puis on va faire aussi estimé le
l'alignement des as ou non par rapport
au sort des toiles qui sert de référence
est donc pareil on va faire aussi les
satellites hier regarder le mot une
accélération induites sur l'instrument
suivant les différents acquis déduire
l'alignement de notre instrument par
rapport aux 100 sur la toile
c'est vraiment une expérience physique
fondamentale donc ce qu'on cherche à
faire c'est donner vu par l'expérience
un certain nombre de valeurs aux
théoriciens qui leur permettent de
régler leurs théories comment s'étonner
dès lors que de grands groupes décident
d'installer leurs centres de recherche
et de développement ici sur le plateau
de saclay dernier en date edf ça y est
le déménagement a eu lieu le site est
opérationnel on attend jusqu'à 3000
personnes
visite guidée avec jean-paul chabat
c'est le directeur scientifique et le
directeur du projet edf lab sackey
vous êtes ici sur le nouveau centre de
recherche d'edf sur le campus de paris
saclay ensemble immobilier comprend
quatre bâtiments 52 mille mètres carrés
de surface de plancher
on a mille quatre cent cinquante postes
de travail qui sont aménagés sur cet
ensemble immobilier et le déménagement
s'est réalisé
au mois de mars 2016 en trois vagues
donc depuis début avril l'ensemble du
site est aujourd'hui opérationnel
les activités de recherche et romaine
ici sont dans des domaines très variés
puisque la la recherche et développement
d'edf travail pour l'ensemble des
métiers
que ce soit le métier de producteur
producteur d'électricité
on travaille également pour erdf filiale
de distribution
et puis on travaille pour tous les
métiers dits aval que ce soit la
production d'énergie renouvelable la
commercialisation d'électricité
beaucoup d'activités également dans les
systèmes énergétiques locaux qui sont
quelque chose qui devient de plus en
plus importants et dans le domaine des
réseaux électriques des réseaux
électriques intelligents également qui
permet justement de combiner réseau de
distribution est arrivé les énergies
renouvelables intermittentes ce site de
recherche c'est vraiment l'outil dont
edf avait besoin pour réaliser la
recherche et développement nécessaires à
la transition énergétique autour d'un
monde avec plus d'électricité et moins
de co2 est aujourd'hui le centre de
saclay c'est un centre qui doit être en
interaction avec son écosystème avec
l'écosystème local donc les centres de
recherche les autres centres de
recherche industrielle le monde de
l'innovation donc pour transférer plus
rapidement les idées nouvelles vers
l'est
et est développé et allemands d'activité
économique donc nous on croit beaucoup à
la réussite les campus de paris saclay
on est persuadé que la réussite du
campus de paris saclay passera aussi par
la qualité de sa desserte par les
transports en commun donc un titre là on
est très attaché à l'arrivée de la ligne
18 dans les meilleurs délais parce que
c'est vraiment un élément clé pour notre
édition d'hier
et on vient de le voir ce territoire
évolué bouge sans cesse le campus
s'agrandit paris saclay est en pleine
mutation
voilà qui suscite des interrogations et
même des inquiétudes
et c'est là que la concertation prend
tout son sens elle permet de faciliter
le dialogue d'échanger de débattre
lucien chabason est le garant de cette
concertation nous l'avons rencontré
voilà une opération qui s'inscrit dans
une longue durée puisque il ya déjà
plusieurs dizaines d'années que les
pouvoirs publics ont transféré ou créer
ici de grandes institutions académiques
universitaire ou scientifiques comme le
cje à l'université paris sud est puis
plus récemment l'école polytechnique
supelec hec et de grands établissements
de recherche
alors évidemment le démarrage de ce
projet a rencontré d'autres visions
celle des agriculteurs ils seront
présents son plateau celle des des
associations qui protège désireuses de
protéger
environnement et le patrimoine qui est
très important ici est celle aussi de
tous ceux qui s'inquiètent de ce que
pourraient être les problèmes de
transport de toute cette population
universitaire en particulier qui
viendraient ici donc les pouvoirs
publics que ce soit l'état les
collectivités locales aussi qu'ils sont
très présentes dans ce projet évidemment
sont confrontés qu'on appelle la société
civile et la concertation
et bien cela consiste à faire se
rencontrer à travers des procédures qui
sont prévues par la loi ou qui sont
créés de toutes pièces ici là ce qu'on
appelle la société civile et pouvoirs
publics de façon à ce qu'ils le dialogue
la concertation apporter dès le début de
2011 2012 sur la délimitation de 7
de cette zone agricole protégée elle a
été assez fait 3 et à la boutique à la
sortie d'un texte d'un décret qui
protégeront qu'ici un vaste ensemble de
terrains agricoles le forez et de zones
naturelles
le dialogue est actif
il reste des désaccords importants il ya
toujours une fraction de la société
civile qui qui regrette l'ampleur prise
par cette opération
d'autres considèrent que ces partis et
qu'il faut l'accompagner que des moyens
de transport et/ou protection dans une
course solide
voilà les termes du débat aujourd'hui
à suivre maintenant notre agenda quels
sont les temps forts à venir on commence
avec le lundi 6 juin et le comité de
suivi des chantiers du quartier du
moulon rendez vous est pris à 17h30 au
plateau des projets de le paix à paris
saclay s'est amorcé un rendez vous à ne
pas rater si vous vous intéressez à la
transition énergétique
l'édition 2016 de dream in saclay aura
lieu du 14 au 6 juin à l'école
polytechnique
objectif favoriser le rapprochement des
mondes académiques et industriels
pour en savoir plus une seule adresse
dreamin saclay points comme et enfin du
27 juin au 1er juillet l'innovation
summer camp prend ses quartiers à
l'estaca à saint quentin en yvelines
le thème retenu cette année repenser les
mobilités au quotidien plus
d'informations sur innovation summer
camp point com
voilà c'est la fin de paris saclay tv on
se retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro est toujours plus d'informations
et d'innovation d'ici là vous pouvez
rester informé sur l'actualité de votre
territoire
grâce à notre site pap.fr ou grâce à tv
fil 78
merci de votre fidélité à très bientôt